hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com
and in this video i want to talk about
the oil
the old price i think it's a very
interesting commodity to look at
because it's actually reflecting for me
uh
how much the economy is recovering
because when the economy is doing well
people need to produce
and to produce they need energy so when
you look at the oil
you're actually looking at it's like a
forward indicator of the economic
recovery so that's very interesting to
look at
let's get into it
[Music]
alright so i'm looking at so in this
chart i'm gonna look
at the crude oil futures quoted
in the new york exchange nymex
um it's very interesting to look at this
chart because as i said
it's like a leading indicator of what
the economy could be doing
in a few month years uh
and when the oil is basically trading
below 50 it's not good
when the oil is trading above 50 it's a
good sign
so let's see let's see here how things
um are going so what i see on the start
so this was the kobe 19 crisis
so basically here you can see that the
oil price actually traded negatively
and this was because some there were a
lot of traders that
actually had some very long positions uh
at the 20 level even the 10 level and
they just needed
to suddenly uh cut their positions
because they could not
receive uh physically barrels of oil
so they cut at a very um
crazy price which was below zero
whatever
now we are in the recovery of this
asset and our support level
is at uh 34 roughly it's the level we
saw
basically um at the beginning of the
month
that we had already uh in june
so this is to me my strong support i
have here
a trend line i prefer uh sloping trend
lines than
horizontal trend lines for the reason
that the market is not
going higher you know step by step you
know it's
waves so here to me i have a wave
that has been uh finished when this
trend line has been
broken and as you can see broken retest
we go higher
so i think that this new resistance that
we have here
which is the highest level that we had
since
march lows is not going to hold
uh i'm bullish from here from 40
and of course we have a resistance here
but
i think that we might break it the
reasons behind it
why i'm a bit bullish on the oil
is because uh as you know we have this
coveted vaccines
uh coming from different um laboratory
we have pfizer we have moderna and i
think we have one more now that have
very satisfying results
of day phase three trials
which is the last phase actually when
you need to do trials
so it's very encouraging i think we're
gonna have a vaccine ready in
um early 2021 that they're able to
produce
hundreds of millions of those very
quickly
so of course the first those are gonna
go to the united states
because this is where those vaccines
have been uh developed
found and tested it's american firms
fisa and moderna so it's not gonna come
to the whole world
right away but it's gonna come soon when
this is gonna happen
the economy is gonna boom it's actually
already booming because of all these
massive money injections that we have in
the system uh
since kobe 19 crisis has started and i
think
this money is going to keep coming
because we need it to save the economy
and it's going to generate some nice
growth for a lot of sectors
as we saw already with the tech sector
but i think that
the banking sector and the industrial
and energy sector
is gonna catch up soon so my view
on all the energy stocks and on oil
is bullish but be careful
of course if we start to trade below the
moving averages on oil
so here the moving averages are at
roughly
40. my trend line as well is at 40 so
basically i'm bullish above
40. and where are my targets my targets
are actually here so here i take the
highest point
uh when the in the move down started
in 2020 so it's at 54.
so this is my first target and my second
target which is
stronger is actually i take
like a very long term move starting in
215
and i do a downward sloping trend line
and this gives me a kind of
a moving target that is today around
58 and that is going to be in next july
around 54. so actually this is my view i
think that next july
so within six eight months i think the
oil price is going to trade around
50 54. here we're gonna have a battle
it's gonna it's all gonna depend on how
the economy is actually recovering
how those vaccines are effective if
people are allowed to travel
or not and this is going to give me more
information that i need to know
what i know as of now is that there was
a
meeting at opec so opec is basically a
group of countries that are
the biggest producers of oil they are
led by saudi arabia
and they have already uh cut the output
production of oil by
something like seven or eight million
barrels it was already in
april or or something like this in may
so basically they keep control on this
price and they know what they do because
it's been a very long time that
they know how to maintain the oil price
at a satisfying level so
they are profitable um in their
industry and i think that the output
production cut is
actually going to decrease but slowly i
think the target something like
6 million barrel a day of
production cuts by the end of 2020
which is still um substantial
so for all these reasons um
i have a strong bullish view on the oil
price
okay that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and once again
if you did please don't forget to click
the like button and the subscribe button
so you're gonna be the first one to know
when i upload anything new
stay close to shore